Jordan a fresh graduate is working as a
sophomore engineer at a big firm saving
money for higher studies one day he came
to know that the bank where he was
saving money got bankrupt and all his
money was now gone with the bank
Jordan was confused how come if the bank
had gone bankrupt his money was also
gone when his friend Jack learned about
this he explained that banks are
basically a centralized system for
storing the data of all transactions
Banks rotate money to ensure the
existence of the money of their
customers for instance the amount of
money appearing on your account is just
a number of value
so if they go through any crisis your
money also comes at risk a real life
example of this was the bankruptcy of
layman brothers when they caused a
global recession
in a nutshell by giving your money to
the bank you're giving control of your
money to someone else and this causes
the problem of transparency
and this doesn't stop there
due to the irrational ratio of Banks and
data present technical failures and
double spending we're due to internal
server issues the amount gets deducted
twice became prominent issues
Jordan was shocked to know such an
in-depth mechanism of Banks and how they
negatively affect their money and
wondered if these issues are so
prominent what is a solution
and that's when Jack replied well there
is a solution and it's Bitcoin
Jordan was confused and asked what
Bitcoin is
Jack explained that Bitcoin is a
cryptocurrency that came into existence
in 2008 a white paper was published by a
guy named Satoshi Nakamoto suggesting a
way of creating a system for a
decentralized currency called Bitcoin
its motive was to show the world that
the decentralized control structure can
work with the institutional government
Bitcoin claimed to create a digital
solution that would solve all these
problems like double spending corruption
and low transparency without the need
for a central Authority
Jordan was excited to know about Bitcoin
but needed clarification about how
Bitcoin can solve such issues that large
institutions like Banks cannot
Jack further explained that Bitcoin is a
transparent Ledger without a central
Authority and works on blockchain
technology
blockchain is a system for storing data
in a way that makes it challenging or
impossible to alter hack or defraud the
system
a blockchain is simply a network of
computer systems that maintains
duplicate copies of all transactions in
a digital Ledger disseminated throughout
the network
and BTC is the currency used to make
those transactions successful and as
there are no middlemen the transaction
cost is way cheaper as each system in
the network carries a copy of The Ledger
or transaction stored in it making it
impossible to hack or manipulate because
to do so you will have to take down or
hack every system or node participating
in the network
Bitcoin is completely digital
Jordan after knowing this asked how it
could solve his problem and how he could
get access to bitcoin if it's completely
digital
Jack explained that one can always buy
Bitcoins once you own Bitcoin it gives
you a specific ID which gives you full
control over your money using that ID
you can send or receive funds in your
Bitcoin account that can be later
converted into any currency anytime you
want so if he would have invested that
same amount in Bitcoin years ago he
could have easily accessed it and it
would have been worth much more than
they were years ago
another reference is a Vignesh
sundarisan famously known as medicovan
who became a billionaire with just five
thousand dollars investment all because
of Bitcoin
so these examples are powerful enough to
establish the fact that Bitcoin is the
best alternative for today's Financial
establishment and also how bright its
future is going to be
well here's a question for you where are
all the Bitcoin transactions stored a
blockchain b digital Ledger C private
key
D crypto wallet think about it and leave
your answers in the comments section and
we will provide the answer next week
give the correct answer along with your
reasoning and stand a chance to win an
Amazon voucher Jordan was slightly
relieved but still curious to know that
if Bitcoin is a solution to all the
problems then why is it not used or
implemented by everyone
Jack mentioned that Bitcoin is an
alternative to the current system and it
cannot be controlled by any bank or
government
although there are some great benefits
of Bitcoin many people like Warren
Buffett and Mark Cuban still view it as
risky big economies including the U.S
China Japan and others have actually
endorsed this currency however this
currency is still clouded in question as
a result of the territorial struggle
many top companies like Microsoft
Expedia KFC and Overstock believe in
Bitcoin and use it as a currency mode
and maybe in the coming years it will
gain more people's trust and ultimately
revolutionize the whole economic system
of the world
we hope you enjoyed this video if you
did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated here's your reminder to
subscribe to our Channel and click on
the Bell icon for more on the latest
Technologies and Trends thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
[Music]